au rwanda la vague des réfugiés hutu
fuyant l'ancienne zone contrôlée par les
françaises semble arriver à son terme
même si plus de cent mille personnes
sont déjà installés dans les camps
autour de bukavu zaïre
dans l'un de ces camps des centaines
d'orphelins vivent dans des conditions
précaires ce sont des enfants de troupe
qui ont suivi la débâcle de l'armée
rwandaise
reportage isabelle bessler et eric mézil
toute la question est de savoir comment
tromper la faim depuis un mois que les
îles les amener à bukavu au zaïre
les 1100 orphelins du camp de pannes
dues passent leurs journées à attendre
le repas suivant ou comment se donner du
coeur au ventre
leur histoire a été bien douloureuse
orphelins de militaires enfants
abandonnés rescapés de bataille
ils ont sauvé leur vie en suivant tant
bien que mal la débâcle des forces
armées rwandaises le fpr prenez les gens
ils frappaient les adultes avec des
crosses de leurs fusils les tuer et puis
ray battait tous les orphelins
alors nous on essaie de leur échapper
pour s'en sortir moi je suis seul à
avoir survécu et de ma famille j'ai
rencontré les militaires en chemin et
c'est comme ça que je suis arrivé ici
avec eux certains de ces enfants étaient
fils ou orphelins de militaires ou de
membres du parti au pouvoir ou pire de
miliciens interhamwe mon grand frère
était allé chercher de la nourriture
avec ma petite vers la zone fpr et il
est tombé sur des soldats qui les ont
pris en otage
après on a appris par des témoins qu'ils
avaient été fusillés
je suis allé à ce moment là chez ma
tante qui vivait à la gendarmerie
je suis resté là prêt quand elle a été
tuée par le fpr je suis parti chez les
militaires pour m'enrôler dans l'armée
peu de temps après nous avons été
attaqués à notre tour par le fpr et nous
avons du fise
moi je veux devenir militaire pour
venger les victimes du s p r je suis pas
encore fatigués de la guerre
voilà pourquoi les ong ne se sont pas
précipités à trie milan ses enfants à
l'art mais qu'ils ont suivi pour
survivre mais le hcr ni la croix rouge
ne se sont encore préoccupés de leur
procurer le plus strict minimum
caritas fournit le riz ceux qui ont une
assiette sans privilégier certains
mangeront leur ration quotidienne dans
un sac plastique pour les loger les
attaques d'al khoms à l'extérieur
partout là où il pouvait où il s'est
caché elle se cache là bas nous n'avons
pas où les logis preuve ils ont besoin
de nous a besoin d'aidé nous a reçus
pour le préparer de la nourriture nous
avons besoin des marmites nous a presque
toute chose nous le vend comme une
assiettée dry avec quelques haricots par
24 heures c'est bien maigre quand on est
en pleine croissance et c'est le premier
effort humanitaire organisé par caritas
l'équivalent du secours catholique au
zaïre pour que ces jeunes ne soient pas
considérés comme des pestiférés à cause
des crimes de leurs parents